>>> MY LORDS AND MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSE OF COMMONS, I AM DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE ADDRESSES OF
CONDOLENCE BY THE HOUSE OF LORDS
AND THE HOUSE OF COMMONS WHICH
SO TOUCHINGLY ENCOMPASS WHAT OUR
LATE SOVEREIGN, MY BELOVED
MOTHER, THE QUEEN, MEANT TO US
ALL.
AS SHAKESPEARE SAYS OF THE
EARLIER QUEEN ELIZABETH, SHE WAS
A PATENT TO ALL PRINCES LIVING.
AS I STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY, I
CANNOT HELP BUT FEEL THE WEIGHT
OF HISTORY WHICH SURROUNDS US
AND WHICH REMINDS US OF THE
VITAL PARLIAMENTARY TRADITIONS
TO WHICH MEMBERS OF BOTH HOUSES
DEDICATE YOURSELVES WITH SUCH
PERSONAL COMMITMENT FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF US ALL.
PARLIAMENT IS THE LIVING AND
BREATHING INSTRUMENT OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THAT YOUR TRADITIONS ARE
ANCIENT, WE SEE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THIS GREAT HALL.
AND THE REMINDERS OF MEDIEVAL
PREDECESSORS OF THE OFFICE TO
WHICH I HAVE BEEN CALLED.
AND THE TANGIBLE CONNECTIONS TO
MY DARLING LATE MOTHER, WE SEE
ALL AROUND US FROM THE FOUNTAIN
IN NEW PALACE YARD, WHICH
COMMEMORATES THE LATE QUEEN
SILVER'S JUBILEE, TO THE SUN
DIAL IN OLD PALACE YARD FOR THE
GOLDEN JUBILEE.
THE MAGNIFICENT STAINED GLASS
WINDOW BEFORE ME FOR THE DIAMOND
JUBILEE.
AND SO POIGNANTLY AND YET TO BE
FORMALLY UNVEILED, YOUR MOST
GENEROUS GIFT TO HER LATE
MAJESTY, TO MARK THE
UNPRECEDENTED PLATINUM JUBILEE
WHICH WE CELEBRATED ONLY THREE
MONTHS AGO WITH SUCH JOYFUL
HEARTS.
THE GREAT BELL OF BIG BEN, ONE
OF THE MOST POWERFUL SYMBOLS OF
OUR NATION, THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD, AND HOUSED WITHIN THE
ELIZABETH TOWER, ALSO NAMED FOR
MY MOTHER'S DIAMOND JUBILEE,
WILL MARK THE PASSAGE OF THE
LATE QUEEN'S PROGRESS FROM
BUCKINGHAM PALACE TO THIS
PARLIAMENT ON WEDNESDAY.
MY LORDS AND MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSE OF COMMONS, WE GATHER
TODAY IN REMEMBRANCE OF THE
REMARKABLE SPAN OF THE QUEEN'S
DEDICATED SERVICE TO HER NATIONS
AND PEOPLES.
WHILE VERY YOUNG, HER LATE
MAJESTY PLEDGED HERSELF TO SERVE
HER COUNTRY AND HER PEOPLE AND
TO MAINTAIN THE PRECIOUS
PRINCIPLES OF CONSTITUTIONAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH LIE AT THE
HEART OF OUR NATION.
THIS VOW SHE KEPT WITH
UNSURPASSED DEVOTION.
SHE SET AN EXAMPLE OF SELFLESS
DUTY, WHICH WITH GOD'S HELP AND
YOUR COUNCIL'S, I AM RESOLVED
FAITHFULLY TO FOLLOW
>>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE WATCHING KING CHARLES AND
HIS QUEEN CONSORT.
KING CHARLES, FEELING THE WEIGHT
OF HISTORY THERE, ADDRESSING
PARLIAMENT FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME AS KING, AS THE MONARCH
HERE AS HE ENTERS THE LIMOUSINE
AND THEY LEAVE WESTMINSTER HALL.
PRESUMABLY ON THEIR WAY HERE TO
SCOTLAND.
YOU WERE SPEAKING ACT BLACKROD
AND THE FOLKS THAT ARE THERE
NOW.
>> THERE YOU HAVE THE VARIOUS
PARTICIPANTS, PRINCIPAL PARTIES,
BLACKROD WHO YOU JUST SAW THE
KING TALKING TO, AGAIN AN
ANCIENT POST.
IF YOU TAKE EACH OF THE PEOPLE
WE HAVE SEEN AND YOU ARE TO DRAW
SORT OF A TRAY UPWARDS HOW THEY
ALL FIT TOGETHER IN HISTORY,
THEY EACH HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
ROLE.
IT'S NOT JUST DRESSING UP FOR
THE SAKE OF DRESSING UP.
WHEN THINGS ARE GOING NORMALLY
AND WELL, YOU DON'T REALLY
NOTICE IT.
IT JUST HAPPENS.
BUT IF THERE IS CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS AS WE HAD, AS YOU HAD,
THEN THESE ROLES BECOME
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEN EVERYBODY
HAS TO DEFER BACK TO THAT WHICH
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
THAT'S THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
TODAY'S ADDRESS TO PARLIAMENT.
>> YEAH.
>> STAMPING, I'M THE KING,
YOU'RE PARLIAMENT, I KNOW MY
JOB, YOU KNOW YOUR'S.
>> DON LEMON HERE WE'RE IN
DEADEN BURG WITH RICHARD QUEST,
ALSO WITH US, CHRISTIANE
AMANPOUR AND MAX FOSTER JOIN US
FROM BUCKINGHAM PALACE.
MAX, THE KING THERE REALLY HAVE
TO WEAVE A TAPESTRY THERE
BETWEEN THE POLITICAL PROCESS,
GRIEVING FOR HIS MOTHER,
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH, HE HAD TO
TALK ABOUT HIS MOTHER'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH PARLIAMENT,
WITH THE HOUSE OF COMMONS AS
WELL.
>> IT WAS INTERESTING WHAT WE
SAW HERE WAS REALLY QUITE
PROFOUND REALLY.
IT'S CONFIRMATION THAT THE KING
WILL -- DARE I SAY STAY IN HIS
BOX.
THE KING IS APOLITICAL.
DOESN'T GET INVOLVED IN
POLITICS.
THE QUEEN WAS ABSOLUTELY
EXEMPLARY IN THAT IN RISING
ABOVE POLITICS.
WE HEARD THE LORD SAYING THE
QUEEN'S FORTITUDE IN FACE OF
ADVERSITY FOREVER REMEMBERED.
THEN WE HAVE THE SPEAKER OF THE
COMMONS SAYING TO THE KING YOU
PLEDGE YOURSELF TO UPHOLD
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES, THAT
IS THAT THE KING DOES NOT GET
INVOLVED IN POLITICS.
THE KING SAID I CANNOT FEEL THE
WEIGHT OF HISTORY AND THE VITAL
PARLIAMENTARY TRADITIONS AND
SAID OF THE QUEEN, SHE SET AN
EXAMPLE OF SELFLESS DUTY, I'M
RESOLVED FAITHFULLY TO FOLLOW.
IT'S REASSURANCE TO THE MEMBERS
OF PARLIAMENT THERE AND THE
LORDS THAT HE WOULD UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE DUTIES OF
THE MONARCH IN THE WAY THAT HIS
PREDECESSOR DID.
SO, WHILE THERE'S LOTS OF
TRADITION AND FORMAL LANGUAGE,
IT'S QUITE PROFOUND.
I THINK EVERYTHING THE KING SAID
THERE WAS QUITE REASSURING TO
EVERYONE SITTING IN THE ANCIENT
HALL GOING BACK MORE THAN 900
YEARS.
>> ELIZABETH NORTON ALSO JOINS
US AS WELL.
ELIZABETH, WELCOME TO THE
PROGRAM.
AS MAX JUST POINTED OUT, CHARLES
SAYS HE FEELS THE WEIGHT OF
HISTORY AND YOU DON'T NEED TO
IMAGINE WHY.
THIS IS QUITE PROFOUND.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLY HISTORIC.
AND OF COURSE, NEW MONARCHS HAVE
BEEN GOING TO PARLIAMENT TO
SPEAK TO THE HOUSE OF LORDS AND
THE HOUSE OF COMMONS FOR
CENTURIES.
SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TRADITION AND, OF
COURSE, TIES IN THE MONARCH TO
THEIR GOVERNMENT.
>> CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR, AS WE
WATCH THE PROCESSION OR WATCH
THE MOTORCADE OF THE KING
LEAVING WESTMINSTER HALL AND
THEN THESE PICTURES NOW INSIDE
OF WESTMINSTER HALL, YOU KNOW, I
HAVE TO KEEP REFERRING TO THIS,
THERE IS A LOT GOING ON HERE AS
IT RELATES TO THE TRANSITION OF
POWER OF THE GOVERNMENT, THE
FUTURE OF THE MONARCHY AND ALSO
LAYING TO REST THE BELOVED QUEEN
FOR 70 YEARS.
IT WAS A LOT -- IT WAS MENTIONED
A LOT, DIAMOND JUBILEE, PLATINUM
JUBILEE, GOLD JUBILEE AND IT'S
JUST A REMINDER OF HOW LONG
QUEEN ELIZABETH HAS BEEN REALLY
HERE AND ON THE WORLD STAGE.
>> WELL, JUST SO YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF CHOREOGRAPHY, NOW THE
KING AND QUEEN CONSORT ARE ON
THEIR WAY TO COME TO WHERE YOU
ARE IN EDINBURGH FOR THE
PROCESSION TO ST. GILES
CATHEDRAL.
THAT WILL BE IN A FEW HOURS.
THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY TO TAKE
THAT FLIGHT RIGHT NOW.
IN THE MEANTIME, HOW COULD YOU
NOT BE STRUCK WHEN THE KING
ACKNOWLEDGED AS MAX SAID AND AS
ELIZABETH HAS SAID THE WEIGHT OF
HISTORY.
YOU KNOW, I COULD ONLY THINK OF
THE GREAT BRITISH RAPPER QUOTING
SHAKESPEARE, HEAVY IS THE HEAD
THAT BEARS THE CROWN.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
EVEN IF IT IS A CEREMONIAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE, WHICH IT
IS.
YOU CAN BE ABSOLUTELY SURE THAT
EVERY WORD THAT THE KING
PROCLAIMS INSIDE THE DEMOCRATIC
HOUSE OF POWER, THE PARLIAMENT,
HAS BEEN APPROVED NOT JUST BY
HIS POLITICAL ADVISERS AND
COUNSELORS BUT BY THE GOVERNMENT
AS WELL.
THERE WAS NEVER A STATE OPENING
OF PARLIAMENT THAT THE QUEEN
DELIVERED THAT WAS NOT WRITTEN
BY THE GOVERNMENT.
AND THAT IS THEIR ROLE.
IT'S NOT JUST HIS WORDS.
I THINK THAT'S VERY, YOU KNOW,
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER.